[MUSIC PLAYING]
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Hello.
My name's Dustin Kirkland.
I'm a product manager at Google.
And I'm joined here with a
friend and colleague of mine,
Ihor Dvoretskyi, who is
the SIG co-chair of SIG PM,
and CNCF's representation
here at the conference, right?
IHOR DVORETSKYI: Right.
Yeah.
My name is Ihor Dvoretskyi.
I'm a developer
advocate at CNCF.
And I am co-chair of SIG
PM, the Product Management
SIG within the
Kubernetes community.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Right.
So I want to talk about SIG PM.
So SIG stands for
Special Interest Groups.
PM is Product Management.
You're the co-chair.
Full disclosure.
I've participated in
that community a bit.
I'd like you to tell us a
little bit about the charter,
and the definition
of that group.
IHOR DVORETSKYI: Sure.
So let's start with from
the entire community, how
Kubernetes community is formed,
and what are the atomic units
of Kubernetes community.
So SIG is a special
interest group.
It's a small unit, but a
basic unit of community.
So every single
piece of Kubernetes
is being developed by some
special interest group.
There can be some technical
and vertical SIGs.
They are called the
vertical SIGs that
are focused on some
specific technical error,
and some specific
component of Kubernetes.
For example, if you are looking
for the special interest
group which is developing,
for example, networking
functionality or
storage functionality,
there are SIG network or SIG
storage within the Kubernetes
community.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Yeah.
I find that super unique, right?
I mean, it makes perfect sense
to have a special interest
group working on networking,
or working on storage,
or working on GPUs
or accelerators.
But this is a special interest
workgroup for an open source
project that's a group of
product managers from lots
of competing companies working
on how to improve product
management around Kubernetes.
IHOR DVORETSKYI: Right.
So product management
group is really
a unique group within
the Kubernetes community,
and within the entire
open source world.
Because, usually, open source
projects are simply projects.
But now some companies are
building their own projects
on top of them.
We have a goal of
building Kubernetes
as a solid product,
even a fully open source
that other companies that
are commercial companies
can reuse them in their
product offerings.
And we have multiple
representatives
from the multiple companies
who are working together
in this single direction.
So SIG PM is a product
management SIG.
Well, it was
established originally
as a working group,
not as a SIG.
So we've been simply
the group of people
who've been interested in
working on the features
and roadmap for Kubernetes.
And we've established the
Kubernetes product management
working group around
two years ago.
And actually some
Google representatives
were one of the
initiators of this drive.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: What do
you see as the key output
of this group?
IHOR DVORETSKYI:
So the key output
for us is driving the features
and developing a solid roadmap
for Kubernetes for
the new year's time.
For the new year's here.
Probably for the next few years.
And another output is to
provide some solid information
for the end users, and for the
render companies who will reuse
Kubernetes for their purposes.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: So just
like product management
at any one of our
independent companies,
Google, Microsoft, any of
the other contributors,
but for the community,
for the CNCF community.
IHOR DVORETSKYI: Exactly.
So we have two
major touch points.
From one side we are speaking
with the end user community,
with the people who are really
using it and consuming it.
And from the other side,
we are working closely
with the technical teams who are
developing some functionality.
So as the SIG PM, we are simply
the proxy between the end
users, between vendors, between
their service providers that
are building some services and
products on top of Kubernetes,
and the technical groups
who are developing
some functionality
for Kubernetes
and within Kubernetes.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Yeah.
This is a fascinating project.
And I hope that if this
group is successful,
we'll see similar groups
emerge around other open source
projects.
Ihor, thank you very
much for your time.
IHOR DVORETSKYI: Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]